you almost have your own world because
we post fan questions you know yeah and
I was going I was just looking them and
everyone everything's mommy jeans a
waterboard champ or water chug champ
like I don't understand it I know it can
you explain any of it it's not even know
how to you know we can not go through
the fan question like I mean I don't
know what this means to gonna have
endless
inside jokes but there's so many people
you know tap it into it that it's like
its own lexicon
it's its own world you're right and I
think they get a thrill they get a kick
out of people who listen to the show art
to your mom's house they get a kick out
of somebody knowing it but I think they
get a bigger kick out of something like
what they're like what are you [ __ ]
lose like you don't know what the water
campus everybody want to be tribal
everybody wants to be part of a like ya
own tribe yeah important it's our
language guys especially like their own
language of course the jeans comes from
what was it meeting that's it's okay it
starts off with years ago I think as a
joke my wife and I you know if I was
leaving the house I'd be like I'm gonna
I'm going out I'll see you later bye
mommy like that like as a silly thing to
say and then it became that there's mom
jeans right so like mommy jeans so then
we started calling each other we drop
mommy
Sarika like other jeans and then see the
jeans buy jeans yeah yes my wife and
then it was like oh if you listen to our
show you know like shows have like you
guys know fire to the kid yeah your own
yeah maybe like a little tag we would
say because you know when you see guys
walking through the airport like dads
like [ __ ] dad official dads show
their khakis yes and they'll wear their
pants high and tight yeah what do
sensible shoes right and absolutely
successful shoes and hats the phone
holster they we would say we would spin
it to like that guy knows what's going
on that's a cool guy
so we would say like if you listen to
our show you wear your jeans high and
tight like a cool [ __ ] bag so then
everybody's like you know if you don't
like our show or if you're like I don't
listen your mom's house they'd be like
oh so you wear them low and loose silly
jokes you know nobody dammit
we need some of that I took marijuana
and I've been talking about this on
state trying to figure it out so I don't
want to sound hacky because I know
there's guys that have done it but I've
had times where your brain starts having
independent conversations with itself
and he's like oh you're so high he's a
gay man do I have a question do I remind
you to breathe and you're like oh [ __ ]
yeah and then and then I remind you and
then you're like wait I'm not breathing
and he's like well we haven't been
breathing in a while like and then you
start going
that's the worst when you start going
you know your heart's racing and I've
had that a number of times and and
that's why I don't really eat marijuana
I'll smoke it but I smoked it in really
small I would do vapor it's very real
small yeah yeah edibles I don't that was
there trouble man like Joey would those
Death Star's dude dude what's wrong with
you man
Joey slipped my dad marijuana you heard
this story yes you tied yeah Oh Joey
comes to Easter one year and he's got
[ __ ] edible popcorn and he goes yo
mr. K you want to see the devil's dip
tonight and my dad's like what's that
Joe he's so aggressive Jim yeah yeah
Easter no no I don't and my dad just
takes a handful of popcorn did he know
what it was I had no idea there's a
picture I don't know where you can find
it if you look online it's on my
facebook my personal one there's a
picture of Joey giving the popcorn of my
dad it's for pictures like that eating
it they're all connected like like like
you're in a meth my sister's going what
the [ __ ] and then me laughing
hysterically and then I was forced to
eat marijuana with my dad so my dad's
like buddy what do I do and I was like
I'll go in with you and so I ate it and
I don't like eating marijuana but we had
the greatest [ __ ] night of our lives
it didn't get weird we're sitting out
it's like probably seven o'clock it's
we're still very high having a cigar
having a whiskey and I say to my dad I
said my dad why don't you like me
because I'm high I'm comfortable and he
goes I don't know I was wondering about
that hold on
this is greatest hold on hold on hold on
I got a good question burst I didn't
think a lot about that late man I can't
figure out it's your [ __ ] face your
whole life is that [ __ ] smirk don't
like that face here the shape your face
was was your dad a season trip realities
he smoked weed
not at all okay this is great okay so
keep going I'm sorry so I he goes I've
been thinking about that a lot my dad
didn't go to therapy now he's high and
he's like he's humbled and he goes you
remind me of my dad and I said okay and
he lost his dad when he was 13 and it
really [ __ ] him up it really [ __ ]
him up forever linked up anybody you
like he'll be walking through Gelson's
and see like a something that his dad
used to like to put on his sandwiches
and just start crying and and he goes
you remind me of my dad and I come
afraid to get close to you because I
look at your lifestyle I think you're
just gonna die and I said okay I go I'm
not gonna die hold on you at this time I
am probably right around for you 42 okay
young and so I go how can we fix this he
goes I don't know I said well like what
an honest guy though what an honest guy
not thankfully we never said it's 42
years go by
yeah hisskill highest [ __ ] yeah won't
you like me think about that man yeah
he's like obviously I love you I just
you make me uncomfortable weird
relationship with their father yes
unaware of it unaware of it until my
parents got divorced
22 to 21 kind of older yeah and unaware
of it that we didn't have like like just
he just didn't know how to like
sometimes you call him and say I love
you and I'll go okay you know that's his
generation
yeah it's his generation and so that I
say to my dad I go I go think how can we
fix this and he goes I just I want I
need I need you to do a lot of things
you're not willing to do I said like
what he goes I need you to get a
cardiologist I need to get he starts
listing off all these things they want
see that you're not gonna die he wants
to prove that I'm not gonna die I go
listen I don't care I go if you want to
you be in charge that and he goes he
literally lit up he's like I can get you
a cardiologist I go you do all of it get
get your cardiologist all your medical
guys you get them online you pick him
for me and I'll go and we'll and that
and he's like he's like you do that for
me I was like yeah I love you like I
don't want I want you to like me like I
want you to be able to have dinner with
my family and not be over judged judging
me everything I do cuz if I would go to
eat something more he'd lose his mind if
I had another drink he'd lose his mind
and he would be very passive-aggressive
his dad passed away from what
stroke and it's and his dad he's like my
dad was the life of the party you seem
to be the life of the party those are
the guys that die fast I just my dad's
never liked that's deep emotion for him
man yeah that I mean I I got chance
that's fascinating to me his dad died it
like 40 yeah have you had a cardiology
that was the babe you can ride he had
biggest problem is I went to the
cardiologist he goes you're perfect I
did a CT scan he goes to zero blockage
and I started eating like a [ __ ] pig
and that's how I got to be 265 pounds is
that I'd literally because they gave you
the game of the green light put me on
all the medicine and I was like so I
can't die well you know you haven't seen
the way I cut catch angles no I haven't
seen it and you haven't seen what
happened to I get hit and I have to dig
down deep cuz I when I dig down deep
yeah you got are you none of you guys in
this [ __ ] room has seen what happened
when I want to dig down deep and what I
do is I take both my hands yeah I make
palms I put my face in my hands and
Shiloh and I'm you cry nope I don't I go
see Uncle Buck no fine
I lock bar which means that is great
don't say occupy walk all right I don't
some difference not not I'm not mousse
less than ice not a Muslim what I do is
I take my hands like this you're right
to think that I would be praying that
way yeah I put my face in my hands
yeah and I'm there ignited yeah I'm
inside my chest I go yeah I go you can
be somebody someday you can be somebody
better you better Tom you're better than
Brennan I just say that because you guys
are there watching ridiculing me yeah
and then I pull my hands away yeah then
you punch yourself in the face and and I
run at him yeah I run out him with miles
a gym I do want to see you fight I look
in the microlights
I look at my go you gonna have to kill
me you're gonna kill me and then it's
just body never watch me die watching
time can we fight for charity why you do
a charity I die dies I die flip both you
off and I just yeah do you guys ever do
a charity thing like that would you ever
if someone came be one was like Tom
Brian listen not against each other but
yeah you know maybe you and Bert I mean
look I would scope out I think it's a if
it's for charity I think like anybody
right you look at what what is the
actual scenario what are we looking at
here let's say I put on a charity fight
night which we could easily do right out
yeah and I have
you and Bert is the main event my god
that would and all the charity goes to
this this kid's home I want Herbert I
was about to say that my biggest issue
when like my trainer wants me to fight
Freddie Prinze jr. for a charity I like
you guys think you know her dangerous
yeah I will if I punch my face I'm not
really I mean if if this use me if I
punch you in the face I'm gonna hurt you
if Freddie box is way more than you do
sir no I know you're a mom I box as much
as he does that's not true is that true
you're on the road all the time i box as
much as Freddie that's not true hey hey
we belong to the same gym I know what
I'm talking about too Freddie yesterday
I know what I'm talking about so can you
just don't talk don't talk how tough you
when I talk no what I'm saying is that
it's not what I was gonna say if you'd
let me finish what I'm saying is that he
wants me to do a boxing charity with
Freddie right I like Freddie Freddie's
great guy the problem with fight with
doing that yeah is that if it's a
charity and people are watching I'm
really gonna [ __ ] box
yeah and I find it very awkward when I
spar yeah to even hit somebody hard with
a jab because it's awkward yeah and
you're hurting them so when I get in
there and I have jabs somebody man why
don't we give you seven let me do hey
dude you got in the ring with man I gave
you a headache and if the guy's pretty
good I don't want to get hit I'm gonna
be trying to hit you back you guys blitz
for charity and you guys don't have
headgear on Sigurd it's for a charity
and also I mean doing it at what it
would Jim do you go to club work you
guys would raise $14 so but if you did
it at the right venue and the right
charity not might you're completely
missing my knowing or not I get what
you're saying I'm telling you if you
guys did it once
trust me both you would be just fine
knock him out Bernard Hopkins I don't
know but wait all I do know Brennan is
that I know this I know you think I'm
gonna come believe Bozzio I'm saying I'm
not saying you're I'm telling you my
buddy would be fine
well well or he wouldn't or I wouldn't
somebody's gonna somebody I've gotten
hit in the head not even that like hard
by a female boxer it [ __ ] really
hurts with yeah I don't think I'm trying
to say is that I first yeah you're not
gonna go balls to the wall try rip in
Freddie's head I'll know otherwise
you're probably not the guy for the gig
right what I'm saying
when people get Andy Dickens but then as
a but when you're sparring and a lot of
people are watching I always feel like
it's gonna escalate like I always feel
like you're gonna get hit I guess what
I'm saying is that I would find it very
awkward I really wrestling jujitsu
somehow if there were you yeah then you
would never do it but that's one could
get guys like Tom and Bert together you
could do it there's a ton of guys you
could do I think it'd be more fun for me
to not do it with Bert though so
honestly cuz you're so close yeah and
it's like you can say just body shots
let's say you're right you're right you
could but I'm saying let's say you're
like look I want to be able to just
punch I don't really want to we're not
saying that you know I would devastate
him but like I don't really want to rock
that you know I mean like I don't want
like to rock my however it's charity
guys who have headgear on 60s gloves
it's still her spreading new Europe Pro
fighters your [ __ ] hurts I don't know
maybe I've seen so many smokers I've
seen these charities before no everyone
walked away just fine I'd be more father
to someone I don't like we'd do that
yeah who's do you not like us to go down
the list so no the way I look as if
you're if you're even remotely athletic
and you've been and you you trained
enough right say you trained three days
a week okay and then you shout out boxer
you can get to a point where you can
actually throw a right hand pretty hard
okay and it's not hard to hurt
somebody's head yeah and I you know I'm
telling you here's the other thing you
forget that like the less trained you
are let's say that's tree and I are in
the ring the less control you have over
oh I'm gonna do it this way and make
sure not to do that for sure instincts
are gonna be means the more exhausted
you get total so after a minute yeah
everyone's me just fine that I'm Tony
Iommi's yeah you're right know your
rights but you guys no one's conditioned
enough you're right now we're gonna go
the other thing is is you could do just
your left hands so you get we tie your
right hands behind you back that's funny
but then it's even crazier or not yeah
yeah for charity depends on the charity
you know I'm saying I have to you'd be
on a mascot you could be a mascot [ __ ]
that's he could be in the seminoles
outfit where'd you go to school
lenoir-rhyne who's the mascot bears
deers boom yeah come on that's a big
beer he's a Seminole yes
I'm in Lululemon I want to wear white
I'm good tight dick yeah you got a nice
ass tank top yeah I'm oiled up [ __ ] was
for the right charity would be fun I
feel like no matter what I'd throw a
[ __ ] left hook and then he'd be like
I do stand-up through a straw now you
never seen that movie oh yeah oh because
of that I [ __ ] up putting a condom on
for the first time yeah do you remember
when they you really got to know this
movie I watch this movie a lot but they
walk the two nerds in the Alfa's do the
Alpha omegas and they see two sheep
there and they go gentlemen and they go
like this with condoms and they roll out
they like oh you know I had I'm unrolled
and they just went blink and I went oh
so the first time I put on a condom I go
you gotta enroll it like Revenge of the
Nerds or the way my mom rolls my socks
up she was all rolled up
so I unrolled it thinking that's how you
put on a condom I never put ID on him
before I'm 17 years old I scoot a slide
it on when I push it over airs trapped
in the side of it and as I push it just
inflates uh-huh and I'm like trying to
squeeze the air out of it like I'm
making a balloon animal
and so I [ __ ] ruin that condom
there's a first time I tried to poke on
tomorrow's do girl yeah I know of course
I remember yeah do you waiting or was it
a One Nights dating dating should go out
to Jeff Hartley he's in the living room
or watching Pet Sematary he's with his
girl we had two condoms we got a member
16 17 years old we got him into exile on
the corner dale mabry and Erlich so I go
over shout to Exxon so I go over I go
hey man I need that I need that other
condom and he's like you already did it
and I go his long story against him and
he was like all right so I grabbed it
and then words like reservoir tip pinch
the reservoir tip make sense to me I
know yeah roll it over even putting it
off felt good I was like whoo I've not
always felt weird
Oh who's the first kind of my better put
on in my life other than the one where I
made the balloon animals so then I get
on top of a real time one done that's
done one pump one pump that I meant done
Wow doggy
of course caught me so off Hardiman me
you premature ejaculation now
I did all through my 20s what mom was
she liked what she looked at me dead
serious looks at my look on my face and
goes are you gonna put it in I missed
her vagina
I [ __ ] between her butt cheek in the
bed and came [ __ ] [ __ ] a man you
came and then I had to [ __ ] her deal
with a compromise here's like going on a
hike going hey why don't you get those
dry socks and shoes jump in the river
real quick dicks barely well at that age
you're good to go my first time you
never [ __ ] with a condom let my me
under like Jack you were never on a big
condom where were you still not there
for [ __ ] so doing syphilis bring it
in my even think if I had my first gay
experience I'd be like bro you're
putting on a condom ladies for all you
know he's got a [ __ ] movie that raw dog
me yes Robin do you like that I'm
getting [ __ ] in his gigs I was like
we're all dog Monroe I want to be
infected that was impressive that was
impressive but yeah touch the condom I
couldn't feel anything so I lasted
forever and it was those so
uncomfortable she was dry it was a
nightmare
Oh nightmare no not not a good
experience nightmares and there's dad
walked in on us oh no and he was drunks
I didn't realize what was going on he
was like hey it's the New Year ball all
right you guys tired you can close the
door I'm like tired I'm balls deep and
your daughter here sir [ __ ]
what would you do that's we'd say you
guys must be tired I went quiet of it I
got stiff then he left she was like oh
my god I'm like anyway
who's not very romantic was not very
porno ish it was gonna [ __ ] with him I
got to drive in a police escort one time
it was one of those things where it's
still one of the thrills from what game
so my buddy's dad was the head coach at
North Carolina said so Tar Heels yeah
and they were playing like hurricanes so
we I flew it out of Miami
how long do was this this was probably
six seven years ago I flew down in Miami
and the night before and where we see
his dad we have dinner with him we're
saying it's his dad you know so we're
having dinner talking all kinds of stuff
but we talk about the game or I was you
know see in the morning so next morning
we go down and it's like four seconds
almost like you forget the level of you
know caliber programs these are so he's
like hey Dad like how do we go to the
game and his dad looks around because
there's the team buses and there's
there's Florida Highway patrolman
motorcycles all these cargo they're
about to escort from the hotel to the
Orange Bowl is when the Orange Bowl was
still there yeah and terrible state and
he goes uh he talks to one of the the
cops he goes it's my son can they and
the guy goes just drive behind the bus
because I have a car and I'm like okay
and I'm forgetting what speed we're
gonna do this at because there's buses I
figured we're gonna go like cruise dude
these buses are doing a hundred down 95
and I keep falling behind a little bit
because I also don't want to run into
the bus I'm like look yeah man so I'm
like I would like dip out you know 85
and that cop behind me would be like
dang is like go go go so we're sitting
there just flying and they closed like
it's like a presidential oh yeah you
know rowboat okay yeah yeah then as we
pull off and we're pulling into the
Orange Bowl this local cop who had cut
stopped local traffic sees me in the
motorcade and he goes you there because
he thinks that I jumped in on him mm-hmm
and then I watch another cop go like and
then we just pulled into the Orange Bowl
and I'm like holy [ __ ] like I mean it
was like the orange ball yeah and it's
also like I feel like I was just in a
race like a legal
and then we just they just the but the
team bus goes down this tunnel and then
they're like I'll just park wherever
okay okay just leave yeah we just pull
in I'm like I just got to go with an
escort yeah 100 miles an hour had your
ear you ever been had your hair cut and
had your ear cut off what do you say
scraped here oh my [ __ ] ears oh oh no
yeah I've got a scar on the top of one
of my ears it's on one of them from my
mom cutting my ear the top off and I was
like oh yes I god I'm sorry I was
thinking of something I was I was it
that might after my first year of MADtv
I'm in New York City and I I got
recognized by maybe three people it was
such a thrill to me like and by the way
to this day when I get recognized I
still it doesn't get old I still will
give the person way too much time like
I'm the guy who actually tires the fan
so awkward he knows his team I go broke
were you act like you've been here
before my thanks and I'm I keep them
there I'm the word I mean I will give
them all the time there while talking
about their family so this this woman
I'm what 27 or so and I walk into it to
get my haircut and a woman who's kind of
young and kind of attractive she goes oh
my god oh my god
I watched you we watch you all the time
my family and I love you um it's pool
boy or whatever and I'm like holy [ __ ]
in the whole place is looking over I
feel like a celebrity I'm like this is
amazing yeah so I go give me a haircut
long story short she first of all
butchers my hair she cuts a super short
inside and leaves the table long I look
like a mushroom I look like a mushroom I
look like a skinny mushroom head I look
like a [ __ ] head like you know that when
they boof your hair all up I'm I'm long
and skinny and my neck is too long
anyway so I'm like now I got like if you
were to bring me down give me a regular
guy I'd be five seven if my neck wasn't
right my height is in my neck and my
Taurus around my [ __ ] hair now then
she cuts my ear so badly
I mean so badly and I'm Bob but I'm like
so gracious because I'm beating up with
it I do it I went oh oh like that I made
a weird noise like that and she goes oh
I'm sorry I go I'm fine it's fine
it's not ugly
so badly that it's coming down my cheek
my legs you have to pay for it dude I of
course because I was like it's fine and
I kept going it's totally fine it's like
a feeling I was bleeding so bad he was
so [ __ ] me my mom wanted me to go get
a tetanus shot I'm like I'm not getting
a tetanus shot what has grown man what
he gave here wait wait wait I had the
worst haircut experience ever I go my
wife but we were dating for months and
she dumped me she was like yes she said
I think you have a drinking problem
party still party party okay so my head
I get my my my barber I won't say his
name he's a hair stylist he used to do
Dave Navarro Ozzy Osbourne here's the to
the star yeah it was hard to get a point
with him he appointment he lived in like
San Francisco need fly down once a month
damn - this guy was great I would hear
this whole place but he would come in
and his haircuts were expensive what
they cost like 120 bucks a while the
[ __ ] were you doing that because because
I was on TV at the time and so and so I
met this guy and I trusted the wake up
my hair went through a 12-step program
with Dave Navarro like like he's the
partier I used to really party yeah yet
to say the least problem he's got a nice
body I used to see him change at crunch
you take a shirt off with his pierced
nipple he's got a beautiful did you ever
see him work out in the hyperbaric
chamber that was off to the left no but
he would kick the bag and do karate and
he talked about his master - I've seen
him in the steam room - and I I could
not stop staring at it
oh it was because Jews all around it
it's wrong you in we've got a dick oh
he's got a [ __ ] you know he keeps that
[ __ ] Bush well manicured and I
wouldn't be surprised if he's got not a
stitch a hair baby my baby's here these
graves eyeliner or whatever yeah um so
so I go in I realized the day after I've
been dumped that I have a haircut and I
call up and I go I'm gonna have to push
it there like he's not coming back for
like another month and a half so I
wouldn't push it so I go [ __ ] it I'll go
in this is how cool it's got a stipple
pool tape
there I walk in he gives me a big hug he
was man you looking down and I go my
chick dumped me because she says I drink
too much he goes man this is my
expertise I mean I'm really dialed in
for this he goes come back we go back to
the bar and he cracks two beers right
and he goes amen
I started partying again I go really and
he goes yeah yeah so I know what you're
going through you say how many people
told you of a drinking problem I go her
and her best friend that's it
here's that's it I go yeah he was dying
sure I said yeah he goes okay here's my
rule if one person tells you how to tale
fuck'em they're crazy if two people tell
you have a tail they're teaming up on
you but if three people tell you have a
tail that's when you need to turn around
and then he says you wanna smoke some
weed guys awesome so yeah you guys I
can't let anyone in here know that I'm
partying like this they know that I had
a beer the other night let's go in the
bathroom so this was the worst guy to
talk to when you're like with you're
trying to fight me over I know what an
enabler he comes out he's like man
nothing like a great haircut man and he
pulls out a razor blade and starts
cutting my hair with a simple jack he's
like I got another guy coming over I'm
gonna go meet her back at the bar I'll
see you tomorrow and I was like I'll
never go to you again ever
thanks for the advice man so bad I went
back by the way you got a tail see you
later
had a mullet like he left this at the
end hair long and he cut my bangs back
to the very top and it was like goofy up
top you're a bad [ __ ] when you
do with a razor though and a thumb a
razor and fun or just hiya shorty - I
mean you're high as [ __ ] yeah yeah I'm
gonna try something on this guy and just
and I don't have hair that you can do
that with in the first place like I'm
holding on to my hair always would you
have done that to Dave Navarro or
[ __ ] Ozzy Osbourne probably not no
but he used to go to Ozzy Osbourne's
house in Dyess and dials Boren's hair
like he had he was go to their houses
and cut their hair he was them he was a
great guy I really enjoyed him but that
one hair that the last here's the last
time I ever saw him man find a legit
like stylist oh yeah I mean I know it
sounds funny
yeah like to find Sony actually cut
here's a Beasley vintage this guy he's
got my wife Sarah and charge a fortune
but he was good he's like really good
yeah and he goes I saw him on set I was
shooting a TV show came over the show
but anyway maybe it was hi might
remember so he he said to my wife he
said happier because I came to pick her
up and he looked at my hair and he said
he said under his breath you should have
your husband come and talk to me he's
not being taken care of and my wife's
like go see him I go mad I'll give a
[ __ ] you know I'm nothing's gonna do so
I see him and he's so great he's a go
what would you do to my hair and he just
loved me he goes magic so they said
magically [ __ ] did magic and I was like
I'm in yeah it would have cost me 20
bucks
never won you never did it nobody
imagined I've kept thinking I just don't
see I'm sorry there's not look at look
at me you're honest with me what are you
really gonna do with my hair and by the
way if you do magic how long is it gonna
last for me you know I just can't I'm
not high maintenance but like you don't
I mean do you seem to be [ __ ] grown
hair like a sprout not losing here I
throw a real game for 25 years you don't
take propecia bro that's what I do
I already said it [ __ ] up his dick
I'll [ __ ] that boss I say game
depression - I've been taking it forever
it's [ __ ] great you take propecia
yeah dude I got to show you my dick
later I have no problem you gave up you
can still help I'm 15 I can [ __ ] I can
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I'll do [ __ ] and then I'll
[ __ ] again you know I can vouch for that
I have sick like I won't upset you were
in the room but I've seen his dick wrong
yeah my dick jad you've had that thing
in your mouth what butt your butt your
butt you're not losing me like if you
have more face on your beard yeah it's I
could I could you rub it on your face no
no everyone who says it looks like I dye
my beard because my might beard when
it's longer you can't see the idea
enough gray I want it short you can see
gray I mean yeah you do yeah I do I do I
die my beard
not not now certain times you get lazy
with it yeah do you really know I
haven't dyed it but I'm going to but for
for men losing like the top your hairs
like the that's probably the biggest
kind of fear if you have you have in
your hair makes me angry Oh your hair
makes me angry I thought about your hair
today cuz I call my guy Romi by this guy
go to now and I said I'm gonna get a
haircut before Hawaii and then I and
then I was like I go I want to do
something different and I thought I want
to do what Brenda does like you know
real tight and then hair and you and I
will never look like him never he's a
different human being this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]